bonjour à tous aux condors a annoncé son
nouveau smartphone le honor 7x le
nouveau smartphone d'entrée de gamme de
chez aux heures d'entrée de gamme ouais
mais avec un écran énorme qui va en
séduire plus d'un on aura tout de suite
donc trois minutes tech
[Musique]
trois minutes tech pour parler du au
nord 7 x on lancerait compteur le au
nord 7 x étaient présentes aujourd'hui
c'est un smartphone qui est déjà sortie
en chine et quelques temps et qui arrive
dès aujourd'hui de le 5 décembre son
marché européen un smartphone qui est
vraiment intéressant et pour un point
principal pour deux points principaux
d'une son prix à moins de 300 euros 299
euros autre point très intéressant c'est
son écran une dalle ips1 écran lcd de
5,93 pouces avec un format de 18 9e en
2160 par 1080 pixels soit du fhd plus
d'un écran bord à bord c'est vraiment
l'intérêt sur un smartphone qui est si
peu cher d'avoir un grand écran qui fait
quasiment 6 pouces c'est pas du oled cdu
spd ont également une 300 euros mais
c'est parfait ça fait le job
côté processeur c'est un kirin 659 hop
d'accord est un smartphone qui a 4 gigas
de ram 64 giga de stockage peut monter
jusqu'à 250 gigas avec une carte mémoire
vous branchez donnant un double capteur
photo à l'arrière un de 16 mégapixels
qui en réalité le capteur principal et
un de 2 mégapixels qui va servir pour la
profondeur de champ alors vous lui
demandez pas la lune il fera le job il
fera des photos qui sont sympas pas
forcément les plus belles du monde mais
une fois de plus nos téléphones 300
euros à l'avant vous retrouvez une
caméra de saïfi en 8 mégapixels tout est
positif vous avez le mode portrait à
l'arrière comme à l'avant pour faire des
scènes fille avec un flou un éphèbe ok
c'est vraiment sympa il ya plein
d'autres effets qui se sont rajoutés des
effets qu'on peut retrouver comme dans
ce match à caen mais des petites
oreilles pour faire des choses un peu un
peu rigolote et un peu sympa vous avez
aussi le gender gucci mode en scènes
figurant ya pas mal de choses à faire
d'ailleurs c'est super intéressant c'est
la reconnaissance aux gestes ça j'ai dit
à tester sur un téléphone de houaïlou et
lorsque vous avez positionner votre
téléphone vous êtes prêts pour faire la
photo vous mettez votre main devant
sarko n'est votre main et paf ça va
déclencher la photo alors pas
immédiatement bien évidemment vous avez
un petit délai le temps d'enlever la
mince nous vous aurez que des photos de
votre moi ça serait con pour vous verrez
plus pourraient apparaître entre les
doigts bon nom côté design vous avez un
design somme toute assez classique sur
le téléphone de ce genre en deux en
métal le capteur digital qui est placé
au milieu des traits agronomiques ans
que vous nous prenez dans la main vous
positionnez votre doigt et vous un seul
capteur d'empreintes digitales
mais ce nul en trois couleurs le noir le
bleu et l'or côté batterie c'est une
premier 340 millions
erreur vous devriez pouvoir tenir 22
jours en stand by sans rien en faire
nous sommes en vidéo 91 eur en écoutant
de la musique et 12h sur internet ça
c'est hypothétique cotées au s en trouve
un emotion hui 5.1 qui tourne sur un
android 7.0 nougat maintenant à qui
s'adresse aux smartphones au nord cibles
très précisément les jeunes alors qu'ils
sont les jeunes 15 25 ans peut-être
mettre 12 25 ans tailleur vous qui
regardez cette vidéo dites moi quel âge
vous avez quel smartphone vous avez et
est ce que le honor celtics pourrait
vous intéresser
très curieux de lire vos commentaires
est-ce qu'il faut acheter ce smartphone
ou est-ce qu'il faut attendre le biou 10
qui sortira à partir de l'année
prochaine crise est une question de
monnaie qui nous rouler si vous avez un
petit budget vous voulez un téléphone
qui tienne la route avec un grand écran
qui dans les standards actuels pour moi
le honor celtics est parfait si
maintenant vous avez un peu plus
d'argent plus de budget que vous
souhaiter attendre
pourquoi pas attendre le honor view
disque sortira ou alors d'autres modèles
d'autres smartphones qui sortiront
l'année prochaine après versailles il en
faut pour tout le monde
en attendant si vous voulez un
smartphone maintenant pour cette fin
d'année avec un petit budget
le au nord 7 x sera parfaitement la
faire voilà ce qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui en trois minutes sur ceux au
nord 7 6 dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire est ce qu'il pourrait
vous intéresser we know est ce que le
prix vous de prouver cette vision est ce
que l'écran roux projet séduisant est ce
que les performances du fonds s
intéressant vous marquez tout ça on en
parle ensemble je vous invite à blesser
des jolies pouces vous invite à vous
abonner à lâcher parce qu'on parle
toujours et toujours et toujours plus de
contenu de high tech d'informations sur
les smartphones les nouveautés ya plein
plein plein plein de surprises à venir
et je vous dis dès demain on va parler
du honor view 10
et ça ça va être très intéressant parce
que ça annonce une nouvelle ère de
smartphones chez au nord
restez connectés soyez sages sont
gratuites et très bientôt